I love virtual reality and I also love
Grand Theft Auto I started this feature
with the full intention of gushing about
how excited I was to combine them and
then continuing on to explain how great
the experience truly was once I got it
working and you would think that the
marriage of the two would yield some
sort of glorious world simulator
permeated with vertiginous freedom and
lifelike immersion well I regret to
inform you that that's not quite the
case let me start by saying that a I
typically have a high tolerance for VR
sickness and B I spent a long time
modifying the field of view options to
try and make GTA 5 work well with the
oculus rift but after several attempts
at extended play all of which ended with
me on the verge of throwing up laying on
my desk nursing a cup of tea I've
decided that I'm pretty done trying to
force games to be VR ready when they're
very clearly not that's not to say there
isn't potential here activities like
driving around can be immersive and
downright blissful with the riff
strapped to your face and it's amazing
to be able to Crane your neck and look
out the back window or the terrified
passenger in your stolen vehicle but the
camera too frequently gets out of sync
with the direction you're facing leaving
you turning strange angles just to look
straight until you recenter the rip in
addition to this the common issue or VR
head look and joystick look conflict is
more of a problem than usual here
turning with the joystick results in a
sickening 90-degree whip pan when you
try to turn your head at the same time
and turning using only your head is
novel for a while until your neck begins
to cedar with the pain of being used as
a steering wheel and your stomach turns
because you've been rapidly swaying your
head back and forth for 20 damn minutes
further when the game takes over camera
control such as when entering a vehicle
or being run over by one the nausea
increases by about a factor of 10
not to mention that post-death camera
zoom down from the sky which may be
worse than actually dying these
shortcomings are not the fault of
developer Rockstar who never intended
for VR to be used with GTA nor is it an
issue with vortex the software that
enables most DirectX games to be used
with stereoscopic VR it just seems that
any experience not designed from the
ground up to be Virtual Reality
accessible is bound to remain that way
unless you have a stomach of iron in the
mental fortitude of a Shaolin monk I for
one do not and will be sticking to more
Koecher VR experiences henceforth
Oh